What is the Council presidency
and how does it work?
The Council presidency is responsible
for driving forward the Council's work.
Each member state is called upon, in turn,
to take on this role and ensure continuity
in the Council's agenda.
The Council presidency has several key tasks:
It plans and chairs meetings of the ministers
and working groups of civil servants
discussing EU legislation in the Council.
But in the case of foreign affairs,
it is the EU's High Representative
for Foreign and Security Policy
who plans and chairs meetings.
The presidency also represents the Council
in relations with the Commission
and the European Parliament.
It negotiates on behalf of the Council
to reach agreement on legislative files
with the other EU institutions.
The presidency of the Council rotates among
the EU member states every 6 months.
This means that each
country takes it in turns
to lead the Council and prepare
a 6-month work programme.
The order of rotation of the presidencies
is set by the Council.
Member states holding the presidency
work together in groups of three, called trios.
They set long-term goals
and prepare a common agenda of topics
to be addressed by the Council
over an 18 month period.
These long-term goals
are guided by the priorities
adopted by the European Council
in its strategic agenda,
covering for instance:
jobs, growth and competitiveness
energy and climate policies
freedom, security and justice
Find out when your country
will next be leading the Council
and much more on Consilium.europa.eu